- We're coming up on award season.
So do you have a favorite
red carpet moment?
You've done a lot of red carpets, right?
So any one that sticks out?
- Well, my favorite award show every year
is the Golden Globes
because it's the first one
of the year and no one's lost yet.
Right?
- Everyone's in good spirits.
- Everyone's in a good mood.
You get to see everyone, all the
big TV stars and the movie stars.
But you don't know necessarily
who's gonna win because
by the time the Oscar
comes out, everyone kind of
has an idea of who's going
to win best actor, right?
But everybody's in a
good mood right there.
And I used to have a
tradition that everybody
was ready to party too.
'Cause it was the first
one kicking off the year
that I'd bring tequila on the red carpet
and I'd be doing shots with
whoever wanted to do one.
Well, listen, I can hold my
tequila, but after a while.
- I've never had someone do
that for me on a red carpet.
I might do red carpets
if that were happening.
- I remember one time Kelly, it was,
I was like in double digits
and I was still holding it
but then I was talking Reese
Witherspoon, and I was like,
I was maybe a little too close to this.
And she was getting
the biggest kick outta,
I said, I saw myself.
I said, oh my God, no more tequila.
- Double digits?
You're the real man.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- I can't do that.
- I'm a real Mexican.
- I was like, I'm texting,
I like tequila too, but I,
I would be on the floor
with double digits.
It would be a different, I'd
be interviewing like this.
They would never allow me to do that.
- It was fun.
But now as you get older, you know,
I gotta, I gotta keep it
in check a little bit.
- Oh my gosh.
It does sound fun though.
- [Mario] Yeah. It's a good time.
- 'Cause sometimes, you know,
people get the same questions,
you know, we often have
to ask the same thing.
So it's like,
it's nice when something
breaks it up like that.
That's fun.
- Yeah. So that's, that's
probably my favorite
to answer your question.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.